สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิง
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะทุกคนนะคะก็
วันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 14
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมีนาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
ผู้หญิงเขียน 6 ครูฟ้าพูด 5 นะคะนักเรียน
บางครั้งผู้หญิงเขาเขียนผิดนี่ 3 เดือน
แล้วนะเรายังไม่เปลี่ยนกันอีก
ปีค.ศอะไรคะครูฟ้า
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันจันทร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 13
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมีนาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันพุธวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 15
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมีนาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
มีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา
เที่ยง
เที่ยงกี่นาที
ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เนี่ยที่กรุงเทพฯนะคะกรุงเทพฯ
เนี่ย
27 องศาเซลเซียส
ไม่ร้อนนะก็โอเคเพราะ
ร้อนนะคะแต่ดู 27 องศาเซลเซียสจริงหรอ
ผู้หญิงจะบอกว่าแอปพลิเคชั่น
โกหกผู้หญิงหรอคะ
ใช่ค่ะ
ทำไม 27 องศาเนี่ยมันร้อนมากๆที่กรุงเทพฯ
เนี่ยมีต้นไม้
นิดหน่อยไงกรุงเทพฯเนี่ยมีตึกตึก
นะคะ
ตึก
ตึกที่สูงใช่ไหมตึกสูงๆเนี่ยเยอะมากๆมี
ต้นไม้น้อยเวลามีลม
ลมก็พัดไม่ได้ใช่ไหมเพราะว่ามันมีตึกตึก
ตึกสูงๆเยอะก็เลยคิดว่าทำให้กรุงเทพฯ
เนี่ย 27 องศาแต่ร้อนมากๆ
แย่มากเลยนะผู้หญิงกรุงเทพฯนี่อากาศร้อน
นะคะไม่ดีเลย
ว่ากรุงเทพฯ
เยอะมากๆเลยนะบางครั้งเนี่ย
กรุงเทพฯเนี่ยเป็นที่หนึ่งเลยมีคนมาๆๆมาก
ๆสมัยอันดับที่ 2 อาจจะเป็น
ลอนดอน 3 ก็ปารีสอย่างนี้เห็นไหม
กรุงเทพฯเนี่ยมีแม่น้ำเจ้าพระยาใช่ไหมคะ
นี่นักเรียนรู้จากกรุงเทพฯไปแล้วแล้วก็มี
ตึกสูงๆเยอะๆ
จะไม่มีตึกสูงๆมากๆวันนี้เนี่ยนะคะครู
หญิงก็จะมาถามครูฟ้าว่ากรุงเทพเนี่ยมีตึก
ที่สูงใช่ไหมมากกว่า
90 เมตรเนี่ยมีตึกที่สูงสูงๆเนี่ยเยอะ
มากๆแล้วตึกไหนที่สูงที่สุดในกรุงเทพฯ
สูงเป็นสูงที่สุด
อันดับ 1 เลยเช็คมาแล้วตึกทั้งหมดน่าจะ
กรุงเทพฯมีประมาณ
500  +  + นะคะตึกสูงๆเนี่ยตึกไหนที่สูง
ที่สุด
นะคะ King  Power มหานครคุณฟ้า
ของเขานะคะนัก
เป็นทรายของเป็นดีไซน์เป็นดีไซน์ของเขานะ
คะอันนี้นะคะนักเรียนนี่คือตึก King
Power หรือว่านักเรียนอาจจะรู้จักในชื่อ
ตึกมหานครนะคะ a นะตึกมหานคร
ชื่อยากนะคะขอดูขอดูโพยหน่อยนะคะตึก
magnolia  Water  Front คอนโด magnario
ไอคอนสยามถูกต้องค่ะอันนี้เป็น
คอนโดมิเนียมนะคะที่แพงมากๆอันนี้ดีนะตึก
magnolia  waterfront  Condo วันนี้คือ
แม่น้ำเจ้าพระยานะคะนักเรียน
แม่น้ำเจ้าพระยาอ้าว C นะคะ C ก็คือตึก
ใบหยก 2 ตึกนี้นะมี BMW เนี่ยนะคะตึก
ใบหยก 2
สูงมาก
สูงที่สุดในกรุงเทพฯตึกใบหยก 2 ตึก
ครูฟ้าตัวสีชมพูผมยาว
คิดว่าอะไรคะ a  b หรือ C
ครูฟ้าคิดว่า
ถ้าแน่นๆๆ
ครูฟ้าคิดไม่ต้องมีท่านๆแทนเดี๋ยวครูหญิง
เฉลยว่า
ถูกหรือผิดค่อยแทนได้ไหมครูฟ้าคิดว่า
มาหานคร
ตึกมหานครเนี่ยนะคะ
[เพลง]
สูงเท่าไหร่
นักเรียนรู้ไหมคะว่าทำไมตึก magnolia
เนี่ยมันสูงทำไมถ้าผู้หญิง
ยอดแหลมตรงนี้แหละมันก็เลยสูงกว่า
มหาวิทยาลัยนะคะส่วนใบหยกเคยเป็นแชมป์
เมื่อก่อนเมื่อก่อนเนอะใบหยกเนี่ยสูง
304 เมตรนะคะสูง
ถ้าไม่มีอันนี้เนาะตึกผู้หญิงก็คิดว่า
มหานครจริงๆสูงกว่านะ
ยังไงคะครูฟ้าเคยอยู่ที่นี่ใช่
In  My  dreed มันไปที่สูงที่สุด
กรุงเทพสวยไหม
สวยนะคะแต่ว่า
ถ้ากลัวกลัวสูงๆใช่ไหม
ก็ไม่โอเคนะคะ
ถึงแม้จะตอบผิดแต่ก็เก่งได้ค่ะอ่ะ
กรุงเทพฯเนี่ยนะคะนอกจากจะมีตึกสูงๆแล้ว
เนี่ยก็จะมีอีกอย่างนึงที่มีมากๆเลยเวลา
นักเรียนมากรุงเทพฯเนี่ยนักเรียนก็จะเห็น
ว่านักเรียนมากรุงเทพฯเนี่ยนอกจากมากินมา
ดูนักเรียนก็มาช็อปใช่มั้ยคะ shopee
มาช็อปปิ้งมาซื้อของ
อืมแน่นอน
ได้กรุงเทพฯเนี่ยมีตึกสูงก็เลยต้องมีพวก
ห้างนะคะห้างเนี่ยอันนี้อันนี้คือห้าง
เซ็นทรัลเวิลด์ใช่ไหมเราก็ไปช็อปปิ้งไป
ซื้อของไปดูหนังเห็นไหมมี SF  Cinema นะ
คะไปดูหนังได้
มีห้างเซ็นทรัลเวิลด์ใช่ไหมมีห้าง
สยามพารากอนอันนี้นะนักเรียน
สยามพารากอน
แล้วก็มีห้างอันนี้ค่ะอันนี้เนี่ย
เซ็นทรัลเวสต์เกต
จริงๆมีห้างห้างเยอะมากๆให้เราไปช้อปปิ้ง
นะคะแต่ครูหญิงจะถามว่าในห้างสรรพางค์
เวสต์เกต
สยามพารากอน
เซ็นทรัลเวิลด์ห้างไหนที่ใหญ่ที่สุดใน
กรุงเทพฯใหญ่ที่สุดเราก็คือเราจะเดินเดิน
เดินเดินเดินอาจจะต้องเดิน 3 วัน
ถึงจะเดินทางทั้งหมด
100% เพราะมันใหญ่มากๆครูฟ้าคิดว่าห้าง
ไหนคะ
คิดว่า
ทำๆๆ
ครูฟ้าถึงคิดว่าเซ็นทรัลเวิลด์
เซ็นทรัลเวิลด์เซ็นทรัลเวิลด์เนี่ยนะคะ
นักเรียนต้อง
รู้นะโอเค
เพราะครูฟ้าเดินในเซ็นทรัลเวิลด์
หาไม่เจอ
ต้องมี Map นะคะถ้าจะเดินใน
เซ็นทรัลเวิลด์ต้องเปิด Google  Map
ถึงจะเดินได้ใช่ไหมแต่ครูฟ้าเก่งมาก
นะคะ
500,000 บาทสแควร์เมตร
[เพลง]
เนี่ยยังมีเซ็นทรัลเวิลด์อยู่นะคะ
พารากอนกับเซ็นทรัลเวสต์เกตเนี่ยเท่าๆกัน
นะคะก็คือ 5 แสนตารางเมตร 5 แสนตารางเมตร
เท่าๆกันเนาะคำถามข้อต่อไปนะคะอันนี้ BTS
นะคะนักเรียนค่ะ
ส่วนใหญ่แล้วเนี่ยนะคะพวกห้างหรือว่าตึก
สูงๆคอนโดมิเนียมเนี่ยมันจะอยู่ใกล้ๆกับ
BTS ใช่ไหม
ใช่ก็จะมี BTS มีคอนโดมีอะไรใกล้ๆนะคะใช่
ค่ะคอนโดที่อยู่ใกล้ๆ BTS เนี่ยก็จะแพง
ใช่ไหมแพงอาจจะ
24 ตารางเมตรห้องนะไซส์ของห้องนะคะอยู่
ใกล้ๆ BTS อาจจะ 5 ล้านบาท
แต่ถ้าอยู่ไกล BTS  24 ตารางเมตรเท่ากัน
อาจารย์ 1 ล้านบาท
ที่ที่อยู่ใกล้ BTS เนี่ยมันจะแพงมากๆนะ
คะคุณหญิงก็เลยจะถามครูฟ้าว่าที่ตรงไหนใน
กรุงเทพฯที่แพงที่สุดถ้าคุณจะซื้อทำเป็น
คอนโดมิเนียมหรือว่าขายของเนี่ยหูแพงมากๆ
เขาจะคิดเป็น 1  4 ตารางเมตรนะคะนักเรียน
เพราะว่าอันนี้มันคิดแบบคนไทยไงถ้าคิดแบบ
นักเรียนก็คือ 4 ตารางเมตรราคา
เป็นล้านใช่ไหมแค่ 4 ตารางเมตรนะคะเป็น
ล้านเนี่ยแพงมากๆนะคะก็จะมี a
ก็คืออโศกนะคะใกล้ๆกับ bts อโศกถ้านัก
เรียน
bts อโศกก้อนนี้นะคะ
นักเรียนอาจจะมองไม่เห็นใช่ไหม
[เพลง]
จะขยายนี่คือแม่น้ำเจ้าพระยานะคะนักเรียน
อโศกใช่ไหม A  bts อโศกนะคะ B สยาม
แถวๆสยามที่แถวๆสยามนะ C อันนี้ใกล้ๆกัน
เลยนะคะใกล้สยามก็คือชิดลม
อโศกนะคะ bts อโศก bts ชิดลม
BTS สยามคุณฟ้าคิดว่าที่ตรงไหนที่แพงที่
สุดในกรุงเทพฯ
[เพลง]
ชิดลม 4 ตารางเมตรเท่ากันนะชิดลมเนี่ยนะ
คะราคา
3 ล้านสามแสนบาท
แพงกว่าหรอสยามใช่สยามเนี่ย 4 ตารางเมตร 3
ล้าน 5 แสนบาท
อันนี้ 2  5  6  5 นะคะหรือว่า
2022 นะนักเรียนสำหรับที่อาจจะเป็น
คอนโดมิเนียมอพาร์ทเม้นท์ขายของโรงแรม
อะไรก็ได้นะคะนักเรียน
สยามแฮงมากๆนะสยามมากนะคะ
สยามก็มีสยามพารากอนนะคะนักเรียนข้อต่อไป
ค่ะกรุงเทพฯเนี่ยนอกจากมีตึกสูงๆมีห้าง
เยอะๆกรุงเทพฯเนี่ยนะคะก็มีคลองอันไหน
คลองคะครูฟ้า
มีคลองใช่ไหมกรุงเทพฯเนี่ยมีคลองเยอะมากๆ
นะคะนักเรียนก็เลยเรียกเราว่าเวนิสใช่ไหม
เหมือนเมืองเวนิสเมืองเวนิสเนี่ยมีคลองมี
คลองมากๆ
ครูฟ้าคิดว่าอันนี้ไม่มีช้อยให้ครูฟ้าคิด
ครูฟ้าคิดว่ากรุงเทพฯเนี่ยมีคลองทั้งหมด
กี่คลอง
1,000 คลอง
คุณฟ้าบอกว่า 1000 ใช่ไหมมากกว่า 1000
นิดนึงมากกว่า 1,000 นิดนึง
1,050
มากกว่า 1,050  1,500
1,500 น้อยกว่า 1,000  500
1,300 น้อยกว่า 1,300
มากกว่า 1,080
มากกว่า
1,120
น้อยกว่า 1,200
1,180
น้อยกว่า
1,170 น้อยกว่า
1,160 มากกว่า
1,160
1,167
น้อยกว่า
1,167  1,165
1,165  1,162
1,162
1,161
1,161 ถูกต้องค่ะ
กรุงเทพฯเนี่ยมีคลองทั้งหมดนะเอาแค่คลอง
นะคะ
1,161 คลองคลองอะไร
ยาวที่สุดในกรุงเทพฯครูฟ้ารู้ไหม
ไม่ใช่เจ้าพระยาเนี่ยคือคลองเนี่ยนะคะคือ
เจ้าพระยาเนี่ยเป็นแม่น้ำใช่ไหมมีแม่น้ำ
เราก็เลยขุดจากแม่น้ำอย่างนี้
แล้วก็ขุดใช่ไหมขุดจากแม่น้ำ
ก็เลยเป็นของ
อะไรยาวที่สุดครูฟ้ารู้จักคลองนี้ค่ะ
คลองแสนแสบถูกต้องค่ะนักเรียนถูกต้องค่ะ
ครูฟ้าครองแสนแสบเนี่ยแหละค่ะที่นักเรียน
เห็นเนี่ยที่เป็นสีดำๆเนี่ยนะคะก็คือคลอง
แสนแสบ
ก็จะมีเรือ
อันนี้ก็สนุกนะคะ The  Fast  and  the
Furious นะคะแต่น่ากลัวนิดหน่อยเขาบอก
ว่าคลองแสนแสบ
มีสวนสาธารณะค่ะครูฟ้าอันไหนคือสวน
สาธารณะคะชี้ให้นักเรียนดูหน่อยได้ไหม
มันมีใหญ่กว่านี้ไหม
สวนสาธารณะก็คือนี่ค่ะ
ใช่สวนสาธารณะก็จะมีต้นไม้ใช่ไหมมีต้นไม้
ต้นไม้ให้นักเรียนก็ไปวิ่งออกกำลังกายครู
ฟ้าคิดว่ากรุงเทพฯมีสวนสาธารณะทั้งหมด
เนี่ยกี่แห่ง
มีไม่เยอะเท่าคลองนะมีน้อยกว่าคลองมากๆ
น้อยกว่า 40
มากกว่า 30  37
ถูกต้องค่ะเก่งมาก
กรุงเทพฯมีสวนสาธารณะเนี่ยทั้งหมด 37 ที่
เองนะคะนักเรียน
37 ที่เนี่ยมันจะเป็นส่วนเล็กๆเล็กๆนะคะ
ที่นักเรียนเห็นอยู่เนี่ยก็คือสวนลุมพินี
คิดว่านักเรียนถ้านักเรียนมาอยู่กรุงเทพฯ
นักเรียนจะรู้จักนะคะส่วนลุมพินี
[เพลง]
คำถามสุดท้ายนะคะ
ที่ไหน
ที่เวลาที่มีคนต่างชาตินะคนจีนคนเกาหลีคน
ยุโรปคนอเมริกามากรุงเทพฯแล้วไปมากที่สุด
คือทุกคนมากรุงเทพฯต้องไปที่นี่ไปที่นี่
นะคะ a วัดพระแก้ว
บีวัดโพธิ์นักเรียนวัดโพธิ์ก็คือวัดที่มี
พระนอนนะคะเนี่ยวัดโพธิ์ C วัดอรุณ
วัดแก้ว
ค่ะ
วัดพระแก้ววัดโพธิ์วัดอรุณ
ใช่ค่ะอะไรที่เวลาคนมากรุงเทพฯแล้วจะไป
มากที่สุด
คนไทยด้วยนะ
วัดพระแก้วเนาะคือวัดพระแก้วเนี่ยนะคะนัก
เรียนจะรู้จักในชื่อ
ลืมแบบพระแก้ว
แกรนด์
เนี่ยนะคะจะมีคนไปวัดพระแก้วเนี่ยประมาณ
นะคะ 10,000 ถึง
30,000 คนต่อวันเยอะมาก
นักเรียนคิดดูนะคะถ้าเป็นนักเรียนเนี่ย
วัดพระแก้วเนี่ยนักเรียนต้องจ่าย 500 บาท
ครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าเนี่ยฟรีนะคะนักเรียน 500
นะคะแต่ถ้านักเรียนอยากจะไปวัดโพธิ์วัด
โพธิ์เนี่ย 200 บาทนะคะนักเรียนนักเรียน
อยากจะไปดูไปดูพระนอนเนี่ย 200 บาทแต่ถ้า
วัดอรุณ 40 บาทนะคะถูกที่สุดเพราะว่ามัน
มีแค่เจดีย์ไงเนี่ยเราจะไปเดินขึ้นบันได
ในเจดีย์ใช่ไหมคะนี่แหละค่ะก็เป็นคำถาม
เกี่ยวกับกรุงเทพฯนะคะ Part  2 นะคะที่มา
เล่นกันให้นักเรียนรู้จักกรุงเทพฯเนาะ
ส่วนวีดีโอนี้คุณหญิงกับครูฟ้าไปก่อนนะคะ
แล้วเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่สวัสดีค่ะ